[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires aussi tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité il est de retour
avec le soleil et les beaux jours le
moustique tigre est désormais bien
implantée sur une bonne partie du
territoire français quelques bons
conseils suffisent pour éviter sa
prolifération nous expliquera la chaîne
8 mont blanc en savoie quelques conseils
peuvent être si utile pour apprendre à
gérer un budget l'éducation financière
s'adresse aux collégiens et les
préparent pour leur vie étudiante un
reportage de vosges télévision dans ce
journal c'est un site magique et
paisible qui fait la fierté des
habitants de la somme les hortillonnages
d'amiens pourrait être sélectionné pour
participer au concours du monument
préféré des français elle ne participera
pas au concours mais il serait légitime
la savane des pétrification en
martinique lieu de rêve volcanique
apprécié des randonneurs photographe ses
producteurs de melons un reportage
éblouissant en fin de journal avec la
rédaction devient atv sur place
[Musique]
ne vous fiez ni à son nom ni à sa taille
le moustique tigre est désormais bien
installé en france depuis une vingtaine
d'années originaires d'asie cet insecte
vecteur de maladies aime les eaux
stagnantes et le ferait pour réduire sa
prolifération la ville d'annecy a lancé
une campagne de sensibilisation
objectif expliquer les bons gestes et
mieux connaître ce nuisible
les agents vont ainsi à la rencontre des
habitants un reportage de manon touati
pour la rédaction de 8 mont blanc
vous les avez certainement déjà vu dans
vos jardins à la proche de l'été le
retour des beaux jours signe aussi le
retour des moustiques tigres ces
insectes prolifèrent dans les zones
d'eaux stagnantes épique énormément en
journée la ville d'annecy lance une
campagne de sensibilisation contre ce
nuisible dans les quartiers des romains
et de l'ovaire chi des agents d'hygiène
parcourent les rues pour avertir les
habitants continuent à faire de la
sensibilisation contre le moustique
tigre pour les riverains ces conseils
leur permettre d'envisager un été plus
sereins bas nous ça fait deux étés où il
est très présent surtout en journée
voilà quand il ya des moustiques tiques
on est dans le jardin en journée l'été
dont on est très vite dévorer on a voilà
on a vite remarqué les endroits où il y
en avait beaucoup l'eau stagnait et du
coup là le fait de mettre des pierres
dans le fond pour éviter que les
moustiques
prolifèrent à cet endroit j'ai trouvé
que c'était une très bonne idée et voilà
je pense qu'on a opté pour ces pierres
et continuer à surveiller les agents
passent de porte en porte et propose un
diagnostic gratuit des espaces
extérieurs les habitants connaissent
déjà les conséquences des piqûres du
moustique tigre mais ignore à quoi il
ressemble vraiment
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
pensent c'est un moustique est vraiment
tout petit c'est pas les normes
moustiques qui vient de piquer la nuit
en fait c'est vraiment un moustique qui
vient de piquer en journée qui est
vraiment tout petit donc par rapport à
une pièce de 20 centimes sur la pièce
d'un centime vous avez un petit globe et
en gros le moustique fait cette taille
d'un est vraiment tout petit il est rayé
noir et blanc donc c'est comme ça qu'on
le reconnaît un bon entretien de son
jardin garantit une limitation de la
prolifération de cet insecte il est
souvent dit que le moustique tigre qui
vous pique est née chez vous puisqu'il
peut se déplacer d'environ 150 mètres
seulement autour du lieu de ponte il est
donc essentiel de connaître les gestes à
appliquer pour éviter son invasion le
but c'est d'adopter les bons gestes pour
supprimer tout ce qui est au stade
nantes puisque quand on supprime l'eau
stagnante on supprime le cycle larvaires
et donc le moustique ne se développe pas
bien sûr on réduit sa prolifération donc
c'est vraiment surveiller tous et
extérieur ranger ce qui a arrangé
et puis effectivement après quelques
petites astuces on peut remplir ces
soucoupes de sable ou graviers pour
éviter effectivement qu'il ya une lame
d'eau et que cette lame d'eau met en å
les yeux qui sont pendus sur les surfs
surfaces verticales la campagne devrait
durer jusqu'à fin juillet la ville
souhaite aussi sensibiliser les écoles
les services publics et les copropriétés
au risque de prolifération du moustique
tigre
elles sont aussi envahissante avec le
retour des beaux jours les chenilles
processionnaires colonisent les arbres
et les forêts vous les avez peut-être vu
dans vos jardins menace pour
l'environnement mais aussi pour l'homme
et nos animaux de compagnie ces
chenilles font l'objet d'un traitement
chimique annuel pour limiter leur
propagation en moselle vous les voyez
sur ces images l'épandage se réalise à
l'aide d'un drone agricole plus efficace
que la main de l'homme il permet de
mieux cibler ces insectes classés
nuisibles pour la santé depuis peu
précision recueillis par chloé gaillard
pour moselle tv
ces bactéries vont être ingérée par les
chenilles qui vont suivre qui se
nourrissent toutes les nuits elles ont
mangé du feuillage qui sur lesquels y
aura des ces bactéries déposés et à
l'intérieur de la tester la chenille il
va se produire un petit un micro trous
qui perforation et la chenille va
s'arrêter de manger donc d'ici
trois-quatre jours lâché ni ne va plus
se nourrir et puis elle va mourir à
petit feu dans votre semaine un mois
voilà et puis soyez prudent évidemment
lors de vos balades en forêt l'émission
politique face aux territoires été
diffusé jeudi dernier sur tv5 monde les
élections législatives ont été
évidemment évoqué à quelques semaines
maintenant du premier tour regardez cet
extrait de l'émission
ses fonctions législatives puisqu'on en
parle vous avez vous créé des surprises
est ce qu'il peut se passer des choses
c'était jean luc mélenchon premier
ministre son nom jean luc mélenchon
prémunissent j'y crois pas parce que
l'arithmétique du scrutin et beaucoup
trop violent dans des législatives il va
y avoir une grosse abstention 53 % la
dernière fois ça peut monter encore donc
il faut être dans les deux premiers pour
être qualifié les triangulaires y en
aura pas il a eu une seule la dernière
fois donc si au deuxième tour vous avez
macron contre mélenchon dans des
circonscriptions l'électorat de droite
et d'extrême droite est éliminée il fera
barrage il fera barrage au candidat
mélenchon tant qu'il y aura un premier
tour peut-être triomphal pour la nuque
et un deuxième tour beaucoup plus
difficiles vont faciliter finalement
majorité la possibilité de la majorité
de se retrouver après ça fera quand même
une opposition extrêmement compliqué à
l'assemblée parce que vous aurez
beaucoup d'élus de gauche et notamment
de gauche radicale mélenchonistes sans
doute beaucoup plus d'élus d'extrême
droite qu'il y en a jusqu'à maintenant
et donc il y aura une taille autour du
groupe majoritaire les débats vont être
très très très virulent groupe
majoritaire qui va vite se diviser en
écurie présidentielle
l'émission face aux territoires est à
voir ou à revoir sur les sites internet
des partenaires de l'émission ouest
france nice matin et vingt minutes tout
à fait autre chose apprendre à gérer son
argent à des collégiens et bien c'est
l'objectif de la semaine de l'éducation
financière organise en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale et la banque de
france celle ci vise à aider et à
sensibiliser les élèves aux
problématiques monétaire qu'est ce qu'un
budget un emprunt ou encore une dette
pour cela rien de mieux qu'un jeu
ludique et éducatif reportage dans le
grand-est d'anthony sap et dan didier
pour vosges télévision regarder quelle
est la durée de validité d'insectes
contracter une assurance payer des
factures gérées son salaire des notions
qui paraissent encore très loin et c'est
assez logique des préoccupation première
de ces élèves du collège de monthureux
sur saône et pourtant les voici mise en
situation au travers de ce jeu de
société intitulé mes questions d'argent
un outil éducatif proposé par la banque
de france en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale ils vont forcément
être confronté un jour à ces questions
d'argent ils vont devoir gérer un budget
c'est vraiment des notions concrètes on
est dans le pratique et on est bien
souvent démunis face à ça on arrive
jeunes étudiants avec un peu plus
d'argent c'est pas facile de le gérer
pendant quelques heures en lieu et place
de leurs cours traditionnels ces élèves
ont d'abord suivi un diaporama pour bien
comprendre ce qu'est par exemple un
budget un emprunt ou des charges fixes
puis ils testeront leurs connaissances
en jouant par équipe en classe pour
décrocher le passeport et d'une fille
d'éducation financière une méthode
amusante pour découvrir cet univers
qu'il l'est beaucoup moins et qui leur
était surtout jusqu'ici inconnu j'ai
appris des choses dont tu es avec moi a
les moyens de paiement que les colis bas
les gens à la caisse ils peuvent refuser
par exemple tout ce qui est au delà tout
d'intérêts et tout ça je ne savais pas
le crédit ce exactement pareil mais les
élèves de collèges ne sont pas la seule
cible de la banque de france qui
s'adresse on le voit ici dans ses locaux
à epinal tout aussi bien un public en
insertion de la même manière au travers
d'un jeu de société mais la jeunesse
reste la priorité ce sont d'ailleurs les
ménages de 25 à 35 ans que le retrouve
le plus dans les dossiers de
surendettement il faut vraiment à
accompagner les jeunes leur donner des
connaissances de base leur apprendre à
gérer à un budget un crédit qu'on
contracte il doit être remboursé et on
attire également beaucoup l'attention
sur les arnaques 25% d'hygiène sont
touchés par les arnaques alors comment
justement se protéger d arnaque mais
aussi comment financer un projet ou
comment faire face aux difficultés
financières les réponses sont sur mes
questions d'argent point fr le portail
national de l'éducation économique
budgétaire et financière
voilà et puis des plus jeunes aux plus
âgés les problèmes ne sont évidemment
pas les mêmes dans la sarthe les seniors
après ne te la base du numérique
utiliser une tablette faire des
démarches sur internet ou envoyer un
mail si cela peut sembler facile
aujourd'hui ça ne l'est pas pour tout le
monde pour aider les personnes âgées les
collectivités proposent des ateliers et
des formations des services précieux à
l'heure du tout numérique et de la
fracture générationnelle
réactions recueillies par hélène galiana
pour alerter les sarthe
c'est devenu un outil du quotidien et
pourtant tout le monde ne comprend pas
la langue alors pour apprendre à
maîtriser les bases le centre communal
d'action sociale de la chapelle
saint-aubin propose aux seniors de se
former au numérique et utiliser des
tablettes sur l'école du numérique
surtout à les rassurer en lui c'est une
tablette avec différentes fonctions très
simple et puis c'est une manipulation
très simple objectif c'est que ils sont
pas perdus dans ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui l'informatique avec un
google etc etc donc des choses très
simples qui puisse manipuler pour avoir
une ouverture d'esprit sur un différend
dans une démarche qui va bien plus loin
que le digital ya pas simplement la
sphère ibérique il ya un respect aussi
de faire sortir les gens de chez soi
l'idée était que on a vécu deux ans que
vides relativement important cet aperçu
que le seigneur nous obligez
pratiquement plus de chez eux ce jeudi
27 personnes ont assisté à la première
formation découverte à écouter en e2 une
équipe qui peut servir de l'ordinateur
si il arrive quelque chose une panne
pour ce soit
un mois je ne sais pas quoi faire
donc il faut au moins dix bals quoi si
vous voulez moi moi ça va ça va parce qu
on a l'habitude quoi mais sinon
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
devant le fait accompli et qui peuvent
pas s'en sortir voilà et c'est compliqué
selon l'insee en france environ 17% de
la population seraient exclues ou en
difficulté avec les usages du numérique
parmi les seniors 53% des 75 ans et plus
n'ont pas accès à internet
capitaine de police est engagée pour la
protection des animaux voilà le portrait
robot de céline gardel une policière
toulousaine qui partage son temps entre
son engagement pour la défense des
autres et des animaux un dévouement sans
limite qui l'a même poussé à créer une
association et à sensibiliser les plus
jeunes un sujet de la rédaction de vioxx
itani regarder
aller 20 ans
protéger les animaux c'est le combat de
cette capitaine de police depuis des
années
ce chien était battu par son
propriétaire avant de lui être retiré un
exemple parmi tant d'autres c'est ce qui
donne du sens à nos journées de pouvoir
les sortir de ces situations qui
finalement sont sont très compliquées
ils n'ont rien demandé ce sont des
atouts à la sensible et non comme un
moyen de
s'en sortir si nous n'intervenons pas un
engagement au quotidien soutenue par de
nombreux bénévoles il ya énormément
d'animaux qui ont pu être sortis de
maltraitance je trouve vraiment que que
en trois ans elle a énormément fait de
fait deux choses
avec nous tous les bénévoles mais
vraiment pour les animaux céline connaît
bien les refuges toulousain à la maison
chiens et chats ont été adoptés filter
c'est ma petite pierre à l'édifice aussi
d'en avoir chez moi et devant occuper
mais ça met beaucoup de vie voilà à la
maison et beaucoup de complicité en 2019
la policière crée même une association
de protection des animaux
car pour mener son combat céline croit à
la formation elle anime notamment des
actions de sensibilisation pour les
enfants ce qu'il a besoin o'shea
il a besoin des croquettes tout ça c - g
cette école a fait appel à elle pour la
seconde fois je trouve ça hyper
intéressant que justement il ya des
personnes qui s'intéressent à cette
situation assez problématique aux
rencontres a fait au quotidien et qui
sont un peu on va dire mis à l'écart
donc il faut les valoriser et je pense
que c'est en commençant déjà froid plus
jeune âge et ont commencé à le mettre en
avant comment on peut peut être évoluer
les choses humainement parlant prochaine
mission terminée la création d'un module
sur la maltraitance animale pour les
nouveaux policiers toulousains les
premiers cours devrait être dispensé mi
juin
voilà une bien belle action en faveur
des animaux qui nous conduit en corse
l'île de beauté accueilli il ya quelques
jours la première course de pas de lan
haute mer 60 participants sont ainsi
partis de calvi pour rallier saint
raphaël sur la côte d'azur un parcours
de 180 kilomètres de jour comme de nuit
comme vous le constater sur ces images
de nos partenaires sur place via télé
pas aisée une performance sportive
jumelées d'une bonne action pour
l'environnement et la protection des
océans l'occasion enfin de rencontrer
quelques géants des mers des images
époustouflantes venue de la méditerranée
sur l'eau mais aussi sur la terre ferme
intéressons nous à une autre belle
initiative celle d'un nîmois qui a
décidé de rejoindre brest à pied en 80
jours un défi de 1400 km relevé par
régis un retraité de 80 ans bénévole
pour l'association les petits frères des
pauvres son objectif changer le regard
sur la vieillesse ecoutez-le au micro
d'eloïse gerenton de tl7 lors de son
passage dans la loire
lorsqu'on a 80 ans lorsqu'on est dans un
âge avancé il faut et on peut toujours
avoir
rêve des projets bref il faut vivre la
vieillesse n'est pas d'une fin la
vieillesse est un est une étape qu'il
faut vraiment vivre
les amoureux de la prunelle de troyes et
de champagne seront ravis les confréries
de ces deux produits locaux se sont unis
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle alliance
objective de ce mariage de proximité
défendre et promouvoir les produits de
la région le tout dans la bonne humeur
comme a pu s'en rendre compte damien art
des oies pour la chaîne canal 32
regarder
[Musique]
une aile et champagne ont célébré leur
union une journée historique pour les
deux confréries nous allons déambuler
pour se retrouver au cellier saint
pierre lieu de distillation de la
prunelle de 3 aujourd'hui c'est
l'apothéose samedi 7 mai nous allons
ont retracé la genèse de nos deux
confréries et que faire un chapitre
exceptionnel de l'air champagne prunelle
[Musique]
objectif de cette alliance valoriser
encore davantage le patrimoine local une
confrérie on est là pour promouvoir les
produits locaux donc c'est vrai que le
champagne est connue la poney les très
connus et on avait envie de créer un
événement autour de champagney prunelle
c'est important de pouvoir marier deux
produits locaux de manière à sceller un
peu plus notre territoire nous allons
vous présenter nos dignitaires et
chevalier quatre ambassadeurs de
l'alliance prunelle champagne ont été
intronisés au terme de cette cérémonie
folklorique parmi eux le président de la
chambre d'agriculture de l'aube alain
boulard et la productrice de télévision
cendrine dominguez c'est très important
de valoriser patrimoine local on a la
chance en france d'avoir un patrimoine
6-1 diversifié si
riche c'est important de perpétuer les
traditions celle ci en fait partie
revenir à 3 pour être la prunelle de 3
je trouve que c'était joyeux inspirant
trouve que la démarche est intéressante
et devrait d'ailleurs même se vulgariser
même à d'autres produits au delà du
folklore et de la publicité que ça fait
autour à la fin de la cérémonie les
quatre ambassadeurs ont réalisé un
cocktail prenez le champagne agrémenté
d'huile de safran de l'aube
un cocktail alléchant à consommer bien
sûr avec modération les rêves sont faits
quant à eux pour être réalisé sans
aucune mesure cela pourrait être l'adage
de sébastien baron un artiste breton
poète et musicien qui a décidé de se
rendre en exploration au groenland son
moyen de locomotion n'est autre kamini
voilier jaune poussin c'est son nom qui
servira de caisse de résonance à sa
pratique culturelle et à ses rencontres
avec les populations locales départ
prévu pour le nord l'an prochain
explications et reportage de claire
villalon pour tvr la chaîne de rennes
bienvenue voici poussins le voilier avec
lequel veut partir au groenland l'année
prochaine et lui c'est sébastien baron
un drôle d'artiste qui a décidé d'aller
au bout d'un rêve peu commun d'imaginer
un tout petit bateau et je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais je lui mets le ciné jaune
et naturellement c'est devenu poussins
et poussins basse pour moi c'est aussi
quelque chose de mignon puis un poussin
sur la banquise qui est le titre le nom
du projet j'ai trouvé que ça avait du
sens ce flibustier des temps modernes
n'en est pas à sa première traversée se
fait un premier voyage dans les eaux
chaudes et puis
donc là j'ai eu cette envie cette vision
d'aller naviguer dans les glaces est
allé à la rencontre des populations
inuits du groenland pour mener à bien ce
projet sébastien fait construire un
voilier sur mesure dans un matériel très
résistant li negra basalte et il a pensé
à tout voici on est dans le carré de
poussins ont l'espace intérieur l'espace
de vie et donc a été conçue dès le
départ un endroit ici même pour m un
instrument de musique et pas n'importe
lequel voici mon fidèle compagnon de
route
protéger des chocs son fidèle accordéon
pourra l'accompagner partout car son
expédition est un savant mélange nautico
artistique l'idée c'est de créer un ciné
concert au retour du voyage avec des
images que je vais prendre pendant le
voyage mais également à la construction
il ya déjà des images qui ont été
tournées et ensuite l'idée c'est de
créer de la musique sur ces images là
que je vais pouvoir diffuser le départ
est prévu en avril 2023 et sébastien
cherche encore des sponsors pour
financer son périple musical et poétique
et en l'écoutant on se dit que la
banquise a bien de la chance
il est l'un des trois sites
présélectionnés pour représenter les
hauts de france lors du concours du
monument préféré des français les
hortillonnages d'amiens font la fierté
des habitants de la ville et de sa
région à cette occasion ou et aux tv la
chaîne de la voix du nord a décidé de
faire découvrir ou redécouvrir ce site
exceptionnel par sa richesse naturelle
une balade au fil de l'eau relaxante
entre faune et flore que nous propose
jérôme homery regardez
c'est une bulle de nature au milieu de
la ville un lieu paisible qui ne
s'offrent qu'à ceux qui en connaissent
le chemin oui pour profiter des
hortillonnages il faut emprunter les
rieux un dédale de canaux façonnés par
l'homme et dont les remous bears est
aujourd'hui les visiteurs c'est
surprenant d'être à côté de la ville et
entend enfin de ne rien entendre
franchement la découverte de cette
nature et
7,7 ce calme et cette verdure
enfin c'est exceptionnel c'est
recommandé presque à tout le monde parce
que c'est paisible et c'est c'est du
calme c'est reposant
de plus le jardin en latin comme orthez
culture à la barre jean baptiste cela
fait quinze ans qu'il voguait fil des
eaux de la somme qu'ils guident les
curieux entre faune et flore entre héron
jeunes foulques et potagers bas voyez là
vous avez mon bureau en décor
le plaisir premier c'est ça quand vous
en avez marre
de la ville
cinq minutes où vous êtes à l'autre bout
du monde vous donniez votre place non
dans ce décor impressionniste réseau
huit cents ans d'histoire l'histoire de
ce qui depuis toujours travaillent la
terre ceux qui vivent au rythme des
saisons jérôme fait partie de ces
maraîchers ils profitent autant de la
terre idéale pour ces légumes que de
l'ambiance sereine des hortillonnages en
haleine le contact à la nature ici qui
est vraiment vraiment agréable le chant
des oiseaux
on a une terre qui est vachement fertile
chaque année plus de 120 mille visiteurs
en barque pour 45 minutes d'air pur
c'est peu mais il n'en faut pas plus aux
hortillonnages pour faire chavirer les
coeurs
et puis des coups vont à présent une
autre merveille naturelle de nos
territoires le trou de bozouls en
aveyron un canyon extraordinaire à l'
histoire plus que millénaire où se
côtoient vers durée cours d'eau au
milieu de falaises vertigineuses un site
extraordinaire dont vous voyez quelques
images impressionnantes
grâce à nos partenaires de la dépêche du
midi direction la martinique pour
terminer cette édition avec d'autres
vidéos éblouissante vous allez le voir
celle d'un volcan totalement décapité
par l'érosion à sainte anne la savane
des pétrification c'est son nom offre un
spectacle quasi lunaire aussi incroyable
qu'impressionnant un voyage dans le
temps est au coeur d'un volcan avec
jean-marc d'abreu était dit albert
journaliste à la rédaction de via à tv
martinique
au sud de la martinique
bordée par la mer des caraïbes une plaie
au faussaire de désir la savane de
pétrification ou la promesse d'un
dépaysement garanti au beau milieu de
cet espace inattendue nous croisons ce
groupe de randonneurs habitués quand je
viens ici en fait c'est parce que j'ai
l'impression de ne pas être en
martinique en fait quand j'ai besoin de
sortir un peu dans mon île sans partir
visiter la savane de pétrification c'est
aussi faire une balade dans le temps il
y à 23 millions d'années l'île aux
fleurs est né ici il reste encore des
traces de cette époque lointaine voila
je viens de
ramasser un morceau de bois pétrifié
type est pétrifié ma réalité c'est du
bois silicifiées pourquoi parce qu'il ya
plus de bons à l'intérieur en fait le
bois il et fibreux un bout de bois
pourri et ce bois a été traversé par des
remontées hydrothermales c'est-à-dire de
l'eau riche en silice qu'on se retrouve
au coeur d'un volcan totalement décapité
nous sommes en train de réaliser là le
rêve un peu fou de jules verne c'est à
dire pouvoir rentrer au coeur de voir le
camp de se passer volcanique découlant
sol argileux et très fertile une terre
idéale pour la culture du melon cette
exploitation d'une centaine d'hectares
ils étaient plantés depuis une quinzaine
d'années les plates
surpuissante et
nous donne un produit de grande qualité
donc le fait d'être à proximité de cette
zone
l'eau nous fait partager la chance d'un
terroir exceptionnel une nature
généreuse et captivante ce photographe
professionnel on a fait son terrain de
chasse soit beau il ya beaucoup de deux
espaces différents que l'on parlait du
patient comme on vient de voir le
balbuzard pêcheur passé
la frégate
le pélican l'impression d'être
sur l'eau avec les oiseaux jadis pour le
plus hauts de l'île la savane de
pétrification offre aujourd'hui un
panorama unique sur la martinique
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi on
se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition en watts
[Musique]